first and we talked about it on the last
podcast you know what why does it
automatically become this thing of like
you're trying to disparage this person
now because your politics tell you yeah
you know have to yeah you can't disagree
because that's funny I was on a group
chat and I'm I'm not to because I'm
doing a lot of organizing other work in
this area right now that like I'm not
competing a ton of attention to like the
details but someone was like now the
police union chief in Minneapolis is
like really going hard on George Floyd's
criminal record right and it's just you
know and it's first of all I mean like
and he has like five priors right and
first of all the first thing that
strikes me is that he hasn't been in
trouble like in 13 or 14 years even if
you I mean do something really horrible
it's like he's gone he's shown
significant reform at least in the fact
that he hasn't had major contact with
the criminal justice system but like I
think a lot of this movement is like
even even though underlying premises of
the criminal legal system in America is
like we criminalize poverty we over
surveil an over arrest black people
right so even like I mean three of the
five cases yes is just like possession
of cocaine and it's like I don't give it
was like oh that's actually I want to
say something I can finish yeah so
there's like I don't give a [ __ ] that he
had a cocaine on him but like in in a
state like Minnesota right like
California thank God we are in a place
maybe six years ago we changed it so
it's no longer Fallone yes right so but
he went to prison several times just for
simple possession of cocaine right a
drug that so many people use in all
kinds of class the classes and all kinds
of colors right but like how many people
use it without going to prison for 10 to
15 months right right and then and then
shocking when he gets out of prison
right it's difficult for him to revive
first family and then he commits other
crimes and it's like and it's like oh
this is so stupid and we invest so
heavily in this like repetitive like
caging of George Floyd and then now the
Minneapolis police officer is trying to
say well he's a career criminal and
that's really this dog whistle right
that's like he deserved to die right
because he was a bad guy right now what
they're trying to engender and imagine
if he was out there doing and then they
create this hypothetical he might have
killed your kid or drunk driver what are
you talking about like let's look at
what happened like he was subdued there
was no reason to kill him and you
for nine minutes well and the fact of
how casual the [ __ ] cops know you had
his hand in his pocket at one point just
kind of looking around yeah it's like
dude what the [ __ ] you are casually
killing a human being in front of people
knowing that they're recording you like
how brazen is that you know what
something like that's just hearing that
[ __ ] it that's the rhetoric and
especially that long 20 minute post that
Candice Owens put out right and just
listening to that is that's exactly what
she was saying it's like this meant why
do we always have to highlight these
criminals and I'm like in that situation
did the what did the cop know about his
noise he didn't know it possibly you use
cocaine three times are you talking
about Candice oh my god dude your brain
cells die man your entire vision I
already even in the her initial
statement when she goes she goes I just
want to say first of all that and I'm
like [ __ ] I already know I already
[ __ ] know she goes I shouldn't have
been killed that way I get better but
[Applause]
all I'm saying is alright it's like III
wanna go back to what you were saying
about the cope with oh yes well I wanted
to ask you something I guess sort of
related to that is um you know from your
experience right like what are your
thoughts on these minimum sentence rules
right against blue collar crimes and
white collar crimes yeah totally okay so
I mean like one of the things that gets
kind of conflated a lot is like minimum
or managed minimum mandatory sentencing
right and that's like that's a really
prevalent in the federal criminal system
okay so which is you know very onerous
and [ __ ] up so for example you know
there's people like I mean I'm one of
the big cases that came out of the
Supreme Court was like some guy was
telling nine ounces of marijuana he got
sentenced to 40 years in prison and this
case went up on review to the Supreme
Court it's like dude this is guys just
selling [ __ ] weed right yeah and the
Supreme Court this is probably in the
80s and was like no that's fine that's
not cruel and unusual and then we
created like I mean so when you get into
federal court and some of these like
higher end possession cases now
obviously these are related to
dealing but I mean even then I have
questions about like even if you're
selling a pound of coke it's like is it
really worth five to ten years in prison
we're in other developed countries these
kind of drug crimes carry like anywhere
from zero to six months maybe a year
right even for like high-volume right
because we understand that people are
gonna use drugs people are gonna come
modify that that that selling structure
right but in state court which is the
vast majority of people in the United
States are incarcerated in the state in
the fifty courts fifty state
jurisdictions right we don't have that
minimum minimum mandatory sentencing as
much we do have like basically a lot of
prosecutorial discretion in terms of
charging enhancements and prior ability
right so up until recently like so I'll
use marijuana as a recent example
marijuana just became legal writing a
California recreationally right so I
mean that first year I petition like I
remember getting one guy a black man out
of prison who was serving an eight-year
sentence okay I don't even know how he
was serving eight years it makes no
sense to me he sold two grams on to like
to one gram a dub sax to a recorded
informant that got him eight years I
gotta make your question and I'm lucky
that guy played because he faced even
more he took like eight years because he
was faced I was a plea deal that's how
can he put an eight year plea deal
because he was so afraid that he would
get 13 or 14 I think after trial that
and because they had a confidential
informant they had an officer watching
the informant me he had no he had no
factual defense to this right I mean he
did it he stole a gram of marijuana to
somebody Wow right and it's just like so
then he can't afford bail right because
it's like a hundred and fifty six some
irrelevant amount to nobody could pay I
mean I couldn't pay it right and so he
gets to couldn't port bail he has a
public defender now the public defenders
is really now wheeling and dealing dude
you have this this is the landscape
right we can go to trial but if we lose
this [ __ ] judge who thinks it's this
biblical mission to put you in prison
for the rest of your life will give you
13 or 14 years the DA saying I'll give
you half of that or you know 2/3 of that
and he's like I'm gonna cut my losses
right I'm and so and I got I mean I got
him out after serving I think he was
serving almost four or six of that
sentence
right and I mean I marijuana them
becomes legal and right make an omission
and I look to injury right and and then
what does the state give him is there
any reparations is there any economic
assistance is there any reentry
programming does he get a preference in
the marijuana industry to get a license
because he wasn't disproportionately
impacted by draconian marijuana laws
nothing he gets nothing he gets out of
released in the middle of the night and
figure out your life right so but in
terms of minimum sentencing so we see
that that's what we see more in state
court we see a lot of these enhancements
oh well if you've ever stole drugs plus
three years if you have a strike prior
times two plus five you know like and
then you start seeing like now all of a
sudden you have like if you have any
criminal history you're looking at 10 15
20 years and you're like dude anything
to the system just has got you by the
balls but yeah and you'll take anything
to reduce your exposure or culpability
and it's very hard to see fighting these
cases and winning when like you know
even the law is perverted in so many
ways even when I have legitimate
arguments under the you know the black
letter rule of the law you'll see like
judges make disingenuous arguments to
like make your job harder because they
don't want your guy to get out or they
don't want to see someone get off on a
with a label is a technicality yeah well
I wanted to ask you because you talked
about that high bail right yeah and so
what are your thoughts then on the bail
system like considering that there's a
disproportionate amount of minorities
from poor like socioeconomic backgrounds
who are getting arrested and and so that
the bail system almost seems to like
reinforce like the wealth gap it's right
100 percent yeah and so it's like it's
basically saying if you're a person who
comes from just decent amount of wealth
average wealth to above-average wealth
who come from a place of privilege you
have the freedom to get yourself out and
fight your case more aggressor
right whereas if you're not yeah too
[ __ ] bad yeah that's what you get for
being poor you know for being part of a
system where there's not enough money
put into education yeah right and it's
it's funny because there's like we're
talking about these Mythos are like the
mythology of America is like about
individualism and meritocracy it's like
well how are you at 18 years old if I
can't afford $50,000 bill how is that my
fault what
I don't have $50,000 like I thought my
didn't choose that but yeah so like I
mean there's been a lot of challenge to
the American bail system recently right
because there's a lot of lawyers working
in this area to say there's this
fundamental premise that if you have
money you can buy justice you can buy
access like look at Roger stone he just
recently you know stood trial and this
[ __ ] I mean he [ __ ] went on
Instagram and put the judge the federal
judge that was trying his case he put
her in a crosshairs and I mean that's a
[ __ ] it was a person of color who not
only not only does he not get remanded
into custody and saying like you're now
at your public safety danger you're
making threats against people who are
involved in your trial right they're
like just don't do it anymore and like
we're gonna monitor your internet and
it's like they will do it they're
jumping through all these hoops not to
remand him right and it's like and back
into custody and it's like well why
don't we do that for people of color or
black people or indigenous people like
we don't offer those same kind of like
like chances we just don't right we
don't see them as a they do it it's a
yeah yeah they're just [ __ ] ridiculous
dude yeah but they also don't see them
like the capacity of rehabilitation or
the community like you know you that
they have and so I mean my question to
that then is like if you're knowing all
this stuff right nope if somebody were
to argue against these points right what
is something that they would bring up to
that they go like you tell somebody like
listen the system is put against him
especially when you put someone and you
incarcerate them for this [ __ ] right
they come out they can't get a job they
have to go back and do it's cyclical
constantly right so what what what does
somebody say to you they go well that's
not true because well I think a lot of
what people say is is they'll go pick an
Adele Terry pic anecdotes to be like
we'll look at this very heinous murder
or this very heinous like crime and then
they'd really like to kind of dive into
salacious details about how it's
impacted certain people or like how this
victim had something happened to them
which you know I'm not unsympathetic to
victims rights right like I think that
that's a very important that we try to
resummon has been traumatized by a crime
right like we need to listen
that person and offer them assistance
and make sure that they get justice
right but I I think there's like two
private things that I respond to with
those kind of salacious cherry-picked
details one a lot of sense my clients
come from communities in which they're
victimized tremendously right like
they've been the victim of tons of
violent crime or abuse or neglect and in
a lot of ways right they're also the
victims of systemic violence right like
I mean when you arrest and incarcerate
their parents and you don't invest in
their health care in education right you
lead to a lot you help contribute to
more violent runs in their life right so
there's both individual like violence
and there's systemic violence that we
are contributing to in their life right
and so that's the other thing I also
think like we were talking about earlier
with your dad like there's a lot of
opportunity for victims to be involved
until I actually have like
rehabilitation like putting someone in a
cage we it's the evidence shows it
doesn't really how it doesn't deter that
person from committing another crime it
doesn't give them the feelings of being
can behave real psychology to be like
you know what I made a mistake I'm never
gonna do that again
that doesn't work like it's not a
correctional facility you know but if
you have like I mean what does work but
we're we are seeing working is like if
someone who has been the victim let's
say a looter is is that it sat down with
the owner of the store and someone who
has the appropriate expertise and
ability to mediate this could say look
at the harm you committed committed to
this family and then and they actually
see the pain and they see the cause and
then and they have this this is how this
made me feel this is why I did it you
see that there is actually dialogue and
you actually the studies do show that
these restorative justice programs
actually contribute to much better
outcomes right on both ends right like
this other person will get you know
oftentimes you know they'll contribute
resources to making sure that they're
whole and then this person who committed
the crime is like oh now I really
understand the the consequences of my
action and and I'm not gonna do that
anymore because and I'm gonna try to do
things to get out of this lifestyle or
make those bad choices that I made it's
kind of like the whole positive
reinforcement force yeah right Balian
yeah a real psychology yeah like if you
give people like this idea of like
understanding a kind of higher level as
opposed to just saying we're gonna put
you into a cage I mean there's a bunch
of Asian parents doing
[Laughter]
you guys wanted the same high school you
guys went to I'm so surprised because I
found out so many things about Whitney
being like a highly accredited school
yeah
[Laughter]